ich rufe auf
die Tagesordnungspunkte 32A bis 32d
Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zur Änderung
des Atomgesetzes zu dem Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung liegt ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu vor über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung und über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der cdu/csu
sowie über die Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen für die Aussprache
wurde eine Dauer von 68 Minuten
vereinbart ich eröffne nun die
Aussprache und zuerst hat das Wort für
die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Harald Ebner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch vor einem
Jahr hätte ich mir nicht träumen lassen
diese Rede hier zu halten und für mich
und meine Fraktion ist sie heutige
Änderung des Atomgesetzes eine schwere
Entscheidung meine große Tochter wurde
im Herbst 1985 geboren und der erste
Frühling den sie erlebt hat war der
Frühling der keiner war im April 1986
war radioaktiver Fallout in weiten
Teilen Europas der die Kinder zum
drinnen bleiben Zwang und kein krabbeln
im Freien auf dem Boden ermöglichte nach
der Reaktorkatastrophe von Tschernobyl
wurde noch deutlicher was fehlen schon
lange klar war Atomkraft ist keine
Lösung und sicher ist nur das Risiko
2001 war der rot-grüne Atomausstieg
geschafft aus dem Union und FDP 2010
wieder ausgestiegen sind aber nach
Fukushima hat dieser Bundestag
einstimmig erneut beschlossen endgültig
aus der Atomenergie auszusteigen und
diese Entscheidung war eine der
wichtigsten Entscheidungen der
Bundesrepublik nach der
Wiedervereinigung mit deren
gesellschaftlicher Großkonflikt
befriedet wurde
leider noch nicht endgültig den nach wie
vor ist die endlagefrage für den
hochradioaktiven Atommüll ungelöst und
der Zeitplan kann so wissen wir heute
nicht gehalten werden der
völkerrechtswidrige Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine stellt uns jetzt vor
neue Herausforderungen
erstens Protein setzt Energie als Waffe
ein und die Abhängigkeit von russischem
Gas die uns in uns in die uns 16 Jahre
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung gebracht
haben hat sie als fatal erwiesen es ist
so und obwohl die deutschen Gasspeicher
dank der Bemühungen des bmwk heute zu
nahezu 100% gefüllt sind müssen wir
weitere Maßnahmen zur Stabilisierung der
Energieversorgung in Betracht ziehen und
drittens die
Atomenergiepolitik unseres französischen
Nachbarn gefährdet die dortige
Energieversorgung massiv weil die Hälfte
der französischen Atomkraftwerke wegen
technischen mängels oder Wassermangel
stillstehen
das stellt auch unsere Energieversorgung
vor Herausforderungen denn damit erhöhen
sich auch die Deutschen stromexporte
nach Frankreich wir stellen uns diese
Herausforderung auf ganzer Linie zum
einen haben wir die 16-jährige Blockade
der Union der erneuerbaren Energien
aufgelöst den ausbauturbo eingelegt auf
allen Ebenen von Wind und Solarenergie
weil es aber nicht kurzfristig durch den
Winter hilft ergreifen wir zahlreiche
Maßnahmen zur Substitution russischen
Erdgases die sind alle schon gelangt
genannt und es ist gut dass wir zunächst
alle diese Register der
Energieversorgung gezogen haben statt
wie andere sofort auf die Atomkraft zu
schielen denn die aktuelle Energiekrise
hat nichts aber auch überhaupt gar
nichts an der Gefährlichkeit atomarer
Technologie geändert ganz im Gegenteil
sie hat uns deren Verwundbarkeit
deutlich vor Augen geführt
gerade wenn wir in die Ukraine sehen wo
Atomkraftwerke zu Angriffszielen werden
wissen wir doch jeder Tag länger bei der
Atomenergie ist ein Tag zu viel und der
Stresstest hat deutlich gezeigt dass die
drei zu Rede stehenden AKWs nur wenig
zur Stabilisierung beitragen können
gerade deshalb wäre die Vorhaltung als
Notfallreserve wie wir sie ursprünglich
vorgeschlagen haben eine angemessene
Lösung gewesen und das Atomkraftwerk
Emsland trägt nun gar nichts dazu bei
ist auch energetisch kontraproduktiv was
in Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
angeht
die heutige Lösung mit sofortigen
streckbetrieb für alle drei
Atomkraftwerke bis längstens 15.04
entspricht dem nur in Teilen wir können
sie aber aus folgenden Gründen mittragen
erstens es bleibt beim Atomausstieg
zweitens
es werden es werden keine neuen
Brennelemente beschafft und damit auch
kein neues Risikomaterial und keine
Grundlage für weitere Verlängerungen
die Union die Union legt uns hier was
vor den Ausstieg aus dem Atomausstieg
alle zwei Jahre wollen sie eine
Laufzeitverlängerung machen sie nehmen
dabei das dadurch entstehende
risikobilligend in Kauf
und wie sieht es in Kauf nehmen haben
wir gesehen mit ihrem Sachverständigen
in der Anhörung der in Bezug auf den
Betrieb von Atomkraftwerken gesagt hat
wo gehobelt wird fallen Späne
Atomkraftwerke sind keine Hobelmaschinen
und den Atommüll können Sie auch nicht
unter den Teppich kehren
meine Damen und Herren ich komme zum
Schluss die zeitlich befristete
Erweiterung des Leistungsbetriebs ist
für mich und die meisten Mitglieder
meiner Fraktion eine Zumutung aber wir
muten uns das zu weil der Atomausstieg
damit bestehen bleibt und weil es im
Gegensatz zum Entwurf der Union keine
Laufzeitverlängerung gibt und keine
neuen Brennstäbe und weil wir keine
Abstriche bei der nuklearen Sicherheit
machen das Wort des Kanzlers ist auch
unseres am 15.4 ist Schluss dankeschön
meine Damen und Herren wer Phoenix guckt
der hat einen Informationsvorsprung
Harald Ebner mein Interview Gast von
eben hatte eben das Wort und sich ein
nächste ist der andere Interview das
Steffen billiger von der Union und
Kollegen und lieber Herr Ebner sie reden
mir zu viel über die Vergangenheit sie
reden nicht wirklich über die Zukunft
sie reden vielleicht wie wir über den
Winter kommen wollen über diesen Winter
aber sie haben nichts dazu gesagt wie
wir über den darauffolgenden Winter
kommen sollen denn da stellen sich die
Probleme noch viel mehr da fehlen ihre
Antworten liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen von
den Grünen auf der einen Seite steht
heute der Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung
ein Minimalkonsens
Ergebnis einer zermürbenden monatelangen
Debatte innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
beendet durch ein inszeniertes Machtwort
des Bundeskanzlers und ich sage es ganz
deutlich ein weiterlaufen der
Kernkraftwerke bis Mitte April 23 bringt
zu wenig bringt zu wenig
versorgensicherheit auch mit Blick eben
auf den übernächsten Winter es bringt zu
wenig preisliche Entlastung für
Verbraucher und Unternehmen und es ist
auch zu wenig europäische Solidarität
das ganze ist ein zu wenig Gesetzentwurf
auf der anderen Seite steht der
Gesetzentwurf von CDU und CSU der ist
eine angemessene und maßvolle Antwort
auf die gegenwärtige Energiekrise es
bleibt beim Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
aber die Laufzeiten werden bis Ende über
nächsten Jahres verlängert das schafft
Versorgungssicherheit das senkt die
Strompreise das hilft der gesamten
europäischen Energieversorgung unser
Vorschlag ersparte Atmosphäre zu dem
viele Millionen Tonnen CO2 zusätzlich
die diese Bundesregierung mit dem wieder
hochfahren der Kohlekraftwerke
offensichtlich in Kauf nimmt unser
Gesetzentwurf das ist deshalb ein genau
richtig gesetzt
jetzt kam hier ein paar Zwischenrufe was
denn mit der Endlager Thematik sein die
Anhörung im Umweltausschuss hat klar
ergeben dass ein weiter Betrieb der
Kernkraftwerke vorübergehend absolut
verantwortbar ist auch im Hinblick auf
die Endlagerung es geht jetzt um die
richtige Antwort in dieser Energiekrise
meine Damen und
weil die Sache ja eigentlich so klar ist
ist die Meinung der Menschen auch ganz
klassisch Stützen unseren Kurs eines
befristeten Weiterbetriebs und die
Menschen in unserem Land haben kein
Verständnis für ihr parteipolitisches
Taktieren meine Damen und Herren
ich will auch deutlich an die Adresse
der FDP sagen dieser Entscheidung heute
zwischen klaren Alternativen kann
niemand ausweichen auch nicht die
Abgeordneten der FDP wer jetzt nicht für
eine echte Laufzeitverlängerung stimmt
wer jetzt nicht für die Beschaffung
neuer Brennelemente stimmt der nimmt
billigend in Kauf dass Deutschland in
der Energiekrise ein noch größeres
Energieproblem bekommt
und deswegen sage ich auch klipp und
klar diese Bundesregierung dieser grüne
Energieminister diese grüne
Umweltministerin tragen die
Verantwortung dafür wenn Deutschland
nicht gut durch diesen und den nächsten
Winter kommt und wenn die Lichter
ausgehen dann werden Sie dafür die
politischen Konsequenzen tragen müssen
Herr Habeck und Frau Lemke
20 von 24 Jahren mit der SPD bitte mal
auch vor der eigenen Haustüren sie
tragen jetzt schon die Verantwortung für
unnötig hohe Energiepreise bis zu 14
Prozent höhere
stromkostenprognostizieren Experten ohne
eine echte Laufzeitverlängerung und beim
Anblick des Stromrechnung kann sich dann
jeder Verbraucher da kann sich jeder
Unternehmer bei dieser Bundesregierung
dafür bedanken und weil diese
ampelkollektion
viel zu lang haben sie für ihren
Minimalkonsens gebraucht Niedersachsen
Wahl grünen Parteitag sonstige
Befindlichkeiten so kann man ein Land
nicht durch eine Krise führen meine
Damen und Herren
Minister Habeck hat ja kürzlich
öffentlich die Arbeitsbelastung seiner
Mitarbeitenden Ministerium beklagt da
habe ich gedacht respektable Geste ein
Mitarbeiter der auch an seine Leute
denkt mir war aber nicht klar dass es in
Wahrheit ja ganz anders das ist schlimm
ist in diesem Ministerium die Fachleute
arbeiten hat aber offensichtlich auch
für die Tonne zumindest dann wenn es
nicht in die grüne parteiprogrammatik
passt das zeigt der sogenannte
Prüfvermerk den bundeswirtschafts- und
Umweltministerium im März angeblich
ergebnisoffen und ohne ideologische
Denkverbote in wenigen Tagen erstellt
haben heute wissen wir das war eine
politische Auftragsarbeit vom Gegenteil
hat uns die Bundesumweltministerin auch
vorgestern bei der regierungsbefragung
nicht überzeugen können Antworten auf
berechtigte Fragen zu Transparenz und
Objektivität fehlanzeige
stellt sich klar heraus wichtige Aspekte
wie der Strompreis der Klimaschutz wurde
bewusst ausgeblendet und noch schlimmer
nicht ins Konzept passende Meinungen
wurden rausgestrichen von Fachbeamten in
Entwurf geschriebene Fakten wurden
rausgestrichen zum Beispiel dass wir
mitten Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke
25 bis 30 Millionen Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr
einsparen können das scheint bei den
Grünen mittlerweile keine Rolle mehr zu
spielen
Herr Harbeck hat in einer
videogrußbotschaft zur Welt
Klimakonferenz gesagt beim Klimaschutz
geht um das Überleben der Menschheit die
Weltgemeinschaft bewegen sich nicht
schnell genug es müssen endliche
Ergebnisse geliefert werden und so
weiter das passt doch nicht zusammen die
Welt belehren und gleichzeitig hier die
Kernkraftwerke abschalten
Kohlekraftwerke zusätzlich ans Netz
nehmen das versteht niemand das versteht
nicht mal Greta Thunberg meine Damen und
Herren ich bitte Sie um Zustimmung für
uns ein Gesetzentwurf
Steffen billiger bittet um Zustimmung
die Union hat einen eigenen
Gesetzentwurf über den nachher auf
namentlich hier abgestimmt wird und die
Union möchte das neue bremsstäbe gekauft
werden und die drei am Netz befindlichen
AKWs bis zum
31.12.2024 Weiterlaufen nächster Redner
kommt aus der SPD Carsten Träger ist der
Sprecher für Umwelt Naturschutz und
nukleare Sicherheit
guten Morgen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deutschland steigt aus der Atomenergie
aus
in genau 155 Tagen ist es soweit und
heute am pulsemörtel
155 Mal werden wir noch wach dann wird
unser Land ein ganzes Stück sicherer
sein
ich weiß ja nicht was sie in diesen 15
April tun werden und bei einigen will
ich es auch gar nicht wissen ich werde
an diesem Tag meine Kinder und meine
Frau umarmen und mit einem Glas Sekt
anstoßen es ist ein Samstag das
gefährliche Kapitel der Kernspaltung zum
Zwecke der Stromerzeugung schließt sich
dann ein für alle Mal in Deutschland
und widerruflich
endgültig es bleibt beim Ausstieg aus
der domenergie damit ziehen wir einen
Schlussstrich und eine Debatte die uns
durch den Überfall von Putins Armeen auf
die freie Ukraine aufgedrängt wurde
niemand hätte in Deutschland noch
ernsthaft anatomausstiege rüttelt wenn
ich das Gas als Rückgrat unsere
Energieversorgung innerhalb weniger
Monate komplett ausgefallen wäre
seit dem arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck
daran diese Energieversorgung neu
aufzustellen und was Olaf Scholz gesagt
hat ist richtig wir müssen über diesen
Winter kommen wir beschleunigen deshalb
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien wir
kaufen fossile Energieträger in der
ganzen Welt wir lassen sogar unsere
Kohlekraftwerke länger im Netz wir bauen
flüssiggast terminals in Rekordzeit
inklusive der Infrastruktur im
Hinterland und wir debattieren eben auch
über den sogenannten streckbetrieb
und wir haben lange geprüft und ich
glaube es ist auch unsere Verantwortung
gewesen als Entscheider in diesem Land
dass wir uns diese Entscheidung eben
nicht leicht gemacht haben die üblichen
Verdächtigen haben es natürlich schon
vorher gewusst dass wir jetzt jahrelang
die Atomkraftwerke weiter betreiben
müssen aber die verantwortungsvolle
Seite in diesem Haus hat sich eben
die notwendige Zeit genommen und diesen
Stresstest durchgeführt und er wurde
nicht von den Ministerien durchgeführt
sondern von den Strom betreibenden
Versorgern von den
übertragungsnetzleistern
und am Ende kommt eine Entscheidung die
nicht jedem von uns schmeckt aber
insgesamt ist es richtig den
streckbetrieb den finden wir
verantwortbar und er wird einen Beitrag
dazu leisten dass wir über den Winter
kommen und deshalb beschließen wir heute
dass die restlichen Brennstäbe die in
den Kraftwerken schon sind dass die
insofern ertüchtigt werden dürfen und
bis zum Ende verbraucht werden dürfen
dieses Ende ist der 15 April das
beschließen wir heute nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
der Stresstest der Energiewirtschaft hat
geteilt gezeigt Atomkraft leistet nur
einen kleinen Teil wir wollen uns eben
bestmöglich vorbereiten die Atomkraft
leistet nicht mal einen Anteil zur
Strommenge die wir benötigen sondern sie
leistet einen Teil zur besseren
Verteilung dieses Stroms innerhalb
Deutschlands weil in Bayern zu wenig
Energie erzeugt wird und weil in Bayern
zu wenige Leitungen für den Transport
von norddeutschen Strom in die
energieintensiven Zentren des Landes zur
Verfügung stehen ja Herr Söder
hätten sie mal richtig für die Zukunft
Bayerns vorgesorgt dann bräuchten wir
den schreckbetrieb nicht machen Sie es
mit sich und ihrem Gewissen aus warum
sie nicht anders gehandelt haben
wir hoffen dass die hoch die
Risikotechnologie die dreieinhalb Monate
nach unfallfrei übersteht denn das muss
man auch mal ehrlich zu Ende denken was
ist denn wenn es nicht gelingt wenn wir
weil wir möglicherweise irgendwelche
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen hinausgezogen
haben und uns dann doch mit der Frage
konfrontiert sehen dass ein hoffentlich
nicht eintreten aber was wäre denn wenn
dann doch ein Unfall passiert wer trägt
denn dann die Verantwortung dafür diese
Frage Herr Bürger haben sie nicht
gestellt und sie haben sie auch nicht
beantwortet ich glaube aus guten Gründen
genau sie werden derjenige sein der ist
an uns verwirrt das kann ich mir schon
vorstellen mit der Werberin Jahreszeit
haben wir es dann hoffentlich geschafft
es bleibt beim Atomausstieg wir steigen
ein für alle Mal aus dieser
hochrisikotechnologie aus und dann
können Sie sich von der Union auf den
Kopf stellen mit den Füßen wackeln dann
ist Schluss ein für allemal
und der Bürger naja
jetzt habe ich nur noch leider 13
Sekunden deswegen
spare ich mir die Replik auf ihre
Ausführungen ich bin froh dass wir heute
einen guten Beschluss fassen werden und
es dann dieses Kapitel ein für alle Mal
beendet ist vielen Dank
kassenträger von der SPD ist zufrieden
das ist mit der Atomkraft im April zu
Ende geht wir sollten bei dieser Debatte
mal darauf achten ob es hier nur um die
Frage geht dass die Atomkraft beendet
wird oder auch um die Frage wie wohl die
Wohnzimmer warm bleiben oder auch nicht
Thomas ehrhorn jetzt für die AFD frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren ich
beginne meine Rede mit zwei Zitaten
erstens Robert Habeck im Jahr 2016 geben
Sie uns noch zwei drei Monate dann
regieren wir diese Republik und dann
wird sich folgendes ändern wir werden
Nord Stream nicht bauen und die
Handelsbeziehungen des gasttransfers zu
Russland sukzessive abbauen weil wir ein
Energiewende Land sind zweites Zitat die
niedersächsische Fraktionschefin der
Grünen Julia williamborg im September
diesen Jahres es ist ein riesiger Erfolg
für die Bundesregierung dass Deutschland
seit 14 Tagen kein Gas mehr aus Russland
importiert was sagt uns das es zeigt uns
das ist schon vor fünf Jahren Bestand
der Grünen Pläne war die preiswerten
russischen gastlieferungen zu sabotieren
und deshalb zeigt es auch dass schon die
ersten einleitenden Sätze des
regierungsantrages falsch sind denn
nicht russland hat künstlich eine
gastnappheit geschaffen sondern sie auf
der Regierungsbank sind es die mit allen
Mitteln diese Lieferung verhindern
wollten und dies durch ihre irre
Sanktionspolitik auch erreicht haben sie
nutzen also ihre verlogene moralpolitik
als Rechtfertigung um ihre eigentlichen
Ziele zu erreichen und eigentlich sollte
es doch auch dem Dümmsten klar sein dass
wir nicht nur in diesem sondern auch in
den kommenden Wintern grundlastfähige
Kernkraftwerke brauchen werden und dass
uns deshalb ein zeitlich begrenzter
direktbetrieb nicht einen Meter
weiterbringt
dass es auch ein Trugschluss ist zu
glauben man müsse nur genügend Windräder
aufstellen dann könne man alles andere
abbauen wenn wir das machen geht halt
bei Flaute das Licht aus das ist doch so
schwer nicht zu verstehen meine Damen
und Herren es sei denn man baut auf den
Import von ausländischen Atomen und
Kohlestrom und begibt sich dann
natürlich in die nächste fatale
Abhängigkeit wenn man dann auch noch
sagt Atomkraft erzeugt zwar kein CO2
wollen wir aber trotzdem nicht
Kohlekraft wollen wir mittelfristig auch
nicht weil es nämlich CO2 erzeugt und
preiswertes russisches Gas wollen wir
schon dreimal nicht weil wir gerne in
Ukraine Krieg zu unserem machen wollen
ja dann ist dies tatsächlich der direkte
Weg in die Zerstörung unserer
Industrienation und der Weg in die
Verarmung unserer Bevölkerung und genau
diesen Weg beschreiben wir ja auch und
deswegen fragen sich immer mehr Menschen
da draußen ob es wirklich denkbar ist
dass es hier eine überwiegend dumme
Politikerkaste einfach nur dumme
Entscheidungen trifft ich kann sie aber
da draußen beruhigen das ist eben genau
nicht so denn wer die tiefrote Vita der
Grünen Partei und ihre Akteure
durchdrungen hat der weiß dass
mindestens die ideologische
Führungselite ganz genau weiß was sie
tut und wohin der Weg eigentlich gehen
soll und einige sagen das inzwischen
ganz ungeniert ich zitiere die grüne
Wirtschaftsjournalistin der taz Ulrike
Herrmann die sich in einem Vortrag nicht
entblöden konnte folgendes zu sagen man
muss sich klar machen das Klimaschutz
den totalen Umbau bedeutet da bleibt
kein Stein auf dem anderen und dann ist
klar dass das grüne das ist das grüne
Wachstum nicht geben wird sondern was
wir haben werden ist grüne schrumpfen
wir müssen raus aus dem Kapitalismus
eine staatlich gelenkte Privatwirtschaft
plus Rationierung
das ist die Zukunft Zitat Ende wer diese
Zukunft will ja der kann bitte auch
weiter Rot-Grün wählen wer das
allerdings nicht will für den gibt es
Gott sei Dank eine Alternative vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
der Bundestag in debattiert über die
Änderung des Atomgesetzes die drei noch
in Deutschland Netz befindlichen AKWs
sollen nicht am 31.12 sondern erst am 15
April abgeschaltet werden und die
nächste Redner in der Debatte ist Carina
Konrad von der FDP die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für diesen Bereich
wir ändern heute das Atomgesetz
das ist eine Frage der Vernunft diese
Entscheidung die ist unumgänglich
geworden und mit der
Laufzeitverlängerung der drei sicheren
und auch der drei klimaneutralen
Kraftwerke Isar 2 Emsland und
Neckarwestheim 2 wird die
Stromversorgung über den Winter
stabilisiert und darum geht es und die
emotionalen reden der Kollegen Harald
Ebner und Carsten Träger haben ja klar
gemacht dass der Weg hierher nicht
einfach war und er war auch nicht
selbstverständlich aber wir haben ihn
nicht zum Selbstzweck gemacht dass kein
Selbstzweck der Ampel dass diese
Laufzeitverlängerung heute beschlossen
wird bis in den April es geht darum die
Menschen sicher über den Winter zu
bringen und den Menschen die Angst zu
nehmen davor dass der Strom ausfallen
könnte dass man kalt sitzen könnte und
das not Elend und Verarmung und droht
und darum muss es gehen und
dafür zu sorgen dass die
Energieversorgung in Deutschland
gesichert ist der endet nicht hier am
heutigen Tag so viel ist auch klar
wir haben doch in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten alle erlebt wie sehr unsere
Gesellschaft strapaziert wird wie sehr
unsere Wirtschaft strapaziert wird wenn
Energiepreise so schnell so rasant
ansteigen
Putin versucht die Grundlage unseres
Wohlstands auszuhüllen und unsere
Industrie unsere Handwerksbetriebe
unsere Mittelständler die sind Grundlage
unseres Wohlstandes in unserem Land und
deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen diesen
Wohlstand auch zu erhalten und eine
sichere Energieversorgung gehört dazu
und wir haben gelernt dass
Energieversorgung nicht nur verfügbar
sein muss Energie muss auch bezahlbar
sein ansonsten wird die Wirtschaft
nachhaltig geschildert geschädigt
arbeitslosigkeiten drohen Abwanderungen
firmenverlagerungen das alles wollen wir
nicht und deshalb treffen wir heute auch
diese Entscheidung und wir haben auch
andere Entscheidungen getroffen auch das
wurde schon erwähnt und wir werden auch
noch andere Entscheidungen treffen
müssen denn wir sehen doch gerade in
einer Zeit in der die Wirtschaft nicht
mehr so stark wächst wie in der
Vergangenheit dass die
Illusion von decross sich nicht
bestätigt sie bestätigt sich einfach
nicht wenn die Wirtschaft nicht mehr
wächst hat das nur Nachteile für alle
und wir haben uns wahnsinnig viel
vorgenommen als Ampel wir wollen die
Zukunft dieses Landes modernisieren und
gestalten und dann muss man auch bereit
sein Entscheidungen zu treffen damit das
möglich ist und die wirtschaftliche
Grundlage in unserem Land auch erhalten
bleibt deshalb müssen wir uns heute
schon Gedanken darüber machen wie wir
über den nächsten den über und den
Winter in zehn Jahren kommen darum muss
es jetzt gehen
und deshalb verlängern wir heute die
Laufzeit der drei AKWs um über diesen
Winter zu kommen deshalb treiben wir den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren und haben dafür
schon wegweisende Entschlüsse getroffen
deshalb treiben wir auch das Thema der
planungsbeschleunigung voran denn wir
haben uns zu bürokratisiert in diesem
Land und deshalb haben wir uns auch ein
belastungsmoratorium verordnet und
überprüfen das Belastungen für die
Wirtschaft nicht überproportional
ausgedehnt werden und deshalb müssen
heute schon an den nächsten übernächsten
und den Winter in zehn Jahren denn und
wer heute den Pioneer gelesen hat der
sieht das gerade auch mit Energie
spekuliert wird 30 Tanklaster mit
lng-gas mit verflüssigem Gas schippern
vor den europäischen Küsten und warten
da dass die Preise hier irgendwann
steigen während unter unseren Böden
genau dieses schiefer-gas schlummert und
auch heute umweltfreundlich gefördert
werden könnte deshalb müssen wir uns
Gedanken machen darüber was geht und wie
wir weiterkommen und das ist der Weg den
diese Koalition geht es ist
natürlich gehen wir ihn wir gehen diesen
Weg und Sie werden sehen
[Musik]
sie hätten sie hätten sie hätten ja mal
für bei ihren Wählern für Zustimmung
werden können dann hätte es andere
Mehrheiten gegeben in diesem Haus
aber kein Stress-Test der Zukunft sein
darf und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
verantwortungsvolle Entscheidungen
miteinander treffen und das tun wir
heute vielen Dank
Carina Konrad Schwell vertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP träumt hier
öffentlich von Fracking in Deutschland
vielleicht hat sie dafür die falschen
Koalitionspartner Ralf lenkert jetzt von
der Linken Sprecher für Energie und
Klimaschutz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Fraktion
DIE LINKE lehnt jeden Betrieb von
Atomkraftwerken ab
und ich sage Ihnen warum erstens
menschliches Versagen beim Betrieb ist
immer möglich siehe Tschernobyl zweitens
Naturkatastrophen sind mit bester
Technik nicht immer beherrschbar siehe
Fukushima drittens seit den
Terrorangriffen auf die Zwillingstürme
in New York kann niemand zu einem
Angriff auf einer Atomkraftwerk
ausschließen viertens seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffskrieges hat die Welt
Angst dass ein Supergau durch
Kriegshandlung passiert
fünftens Materialalterung auch
unvorhergesehene Materialverschleiß
unsachgemäße Reparaturen aber auch
fehlendes Kühlwasser erhöhen die Risiken
von Atomkraftwerken
siehe Frankreich wo nur 27 von
eigentlich 56 Reaktoren Strom liefern 6
weltweit gibt es nach wie vor kein
Endlager für Atome und niemand will
Atome vor seiner eigenen Haustür haben
siebentens kein Atomkraftwerk keine
Atomanlage ist versichert also liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger soll dir Eigentum
bei einem Unfall verstrahlt werden sie
kriegen nichts ersetzt 8 ohne Subvention
ist Atomstrom mehr als vier Mal so teuer
wie heute gewinnkraftanlagen
9 54 Prozent des angereicherten Urans
kommen aus Russland wie kann man da
die haben von der Union AFD ernsthaft
russisches Uran als Alternative zu
russischen gasansehen
zehntens
Uranförderung belastet die Umwelt schwer
das weiß ich als Ostthüringer und die
Sanierung des Uranbergbaus kostete
Deutschland bisher mehr als 7 Milliarden
Euro und tausende Bergarbeiter bezahlten
die Förderung mit ihrer Gesundheit und
11 die deutschen Atomkraftwerke müssen
auch heute nur den technischen Stand von
1980 nachweisen das kann doch nicht wahr
sein
als Techniker in der Industrie musste
ich oft erleben dass nicht die beste
oder die sicherste Lösung umgesetzt
wurde sondern meistens die billigste
es bleibt dabei die Linke lehnt
Atomkraft aus diesen guten Gründen ab
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht wegen
des russischen Angriffskrieges nicht
wegen des Atomausstieges und nur wenig
bedingt durch die Gaspreise explodieren
die Strompreise falsche Marktregeln und
Spekulationen sind die Hauptursache für
den Strompreisanstieg
und um die Strompreise zu senken
brauchen wir keinen striktbetrieb von
Atomkraftwerken wir brauchen neue und
strenge Regeln im Stromsystem statt
Übertragungsnetzbetreibern Profite aus
Netzentgelten zu garantieren fordert DIE
LINKE die Übertragungsnetze zu
verstaatlichen
und wir fordern einen preiswertes
grundkontingent an Strom für Haushalte
Landwirtschaft und Handwerk
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger selbst bei
wenig Wind und keiner Sonne gibt es noch
genügend
Stromerzeugungskapazitäten in
Deutschland und unsere Versorgung zu
sichern das größte Risiko für unsere
Stromversorgung geht von Spekulation mit
Strom aus und von veralteten und
falschen stromaggregern
im juni 2019 standen wir drei mal kurz
vor einem Blackout weil wegen
Bilanzfälschung
unser Stromsystem überlastet wurde und
die bilanzfläche und hatten nur einen
Sinn die Gewinnmargen der entsprechenden
Händler zu steigern und das ist das
eigentliche Risiko für unsere sichere
Stromversorgung
für die Linke ist Stromversorgung
Daseinsvorsorge das Stromsystem muss
Teil vergesellschaftet werden ohne wenn
und aber
und abschließend
ohne Atomkraftwerke gäbe es keine
Atombomben das sind Zwillinge auch aus
diesem Grund muss man Atomkraft ablehnen
atomstrom ist keine Lösung Atomkraft
schafft nur neue Probleme vielen Dank
so weit Ralf Linkert für die Bündnis
Grünen und Sie sehen es hier Steffi
Lemke sitzt hier auf der Regierungsbank
aber der nächste Redner ist nicht etwa
die Ministerin sondern Christian kühn da
steht auch schon auf von den Bündnis
grünen er ist der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär bei Lemke die in der
ersten Lesung am Mittwoch gesagt hat es
wäre absolut fahrlässig auf den Beitrag
der drei AKWs zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zu
verzichten ja sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dieser Gesetzentwurf reiht sich
ein in die vielen Maßnahmen die diese
Bundesregierung ergriffen hat zu
Bewältigung der aktuellen Krise damit
Deutschland gut durch diesen Winter
kommt drei Gründe drei Gründe machen
diesen Gesetzentwurf notwendig erstens
der Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die
Ukraine und die dadurch ausgelöste
Energiekrise
zweitens die Krise der französischen
atomflotte dort steht die Hälfte der
Kraftwerke aktuell still aufgrund
massiver Sicherheitsprobleme der
Technologie der Atomkraft und drittens
das energiepolitische Fiasko aus 16
Jahren CDU geführter Bundesregierung
eine Melange eine Melange aus
Abhängigkeiten zu russischen Gas und
einer blockierten unverzögerten
Energiewende diese Bundesregierung diese
Bundesregierung handelt in diesen Tagen
zutiefst pragmatisch dieser
Gesetzentwurf und es wurde hier mehrfach
betont ist weder ein Herzensanliegen der
Grünen noch der SPD noch der FDP er ist
pragmatisch im Kern weil er eine
Entscheidung ist die auf den Ergebnissen
des Stresstestes beruht
und wir haben es uns wahrlich nicht
einfach gemacht mit dieser Entscheidung
aber eine einfache Entscheidung wäre
angesichts der Tragweite dieser
Verantwortung nicht gerecht geworden
meine Damen und Herren
wir halten am Atomausstieg fest mit
diesem Gesetz und gleichzeitig tun wir
das Notwendige um gut durch diesen
Winter zu kommen und die Netzstabilität
zu gewährleisten nicht mehr und nicht
weniger und ich habe ihn in der Union in
den letzten Tagen vor allem in dieser
Woche auch im Ausschuss hier im Plenum
sehr genau zugehört sie planen nichts
anderes als den Ausstieg aus dem
Atomausstieg sind sie doch mal so
ehrlich und sagen das hier auch sagen
das hier auch
sie haben 2011 den Ausstieg unter der
Bundeskanzler Frau Dr Merkel hier auf
den Weg gebracht und heute fordern Sie
den Betrieb der Atomkraftwerke bis zum
Sankt nimmerland-tag sie wollen neue
Brennelemente beschaffen sie wollen mehr
Atommüll in Deutschland produzieren und
damit das nukleare Risiko in diesem Land
erhöhen das ist die Wahrheit und das
muss heute auch gesagt werden
und sie wollen das nur aus einem Grund
weil sie bei der Atomkraft ideologisch
getrieben sind bis heute bis heute und
weil sie Herr Merz der Vergangenheit
angehören und nicht in die Zukunft
blicken und das zeigt auch ihr
Gesetzentwurf den sie heute mit
eingebracht haben ihr Gesetzentwurf
vermischt nämlich Betrieb und Aufsicht
bei der Frage wie sie die Atomkraft
weiter betreiben wollen und das ist
angesichts dieser fragweite dieser
Fragen angesichts der Frage der
nuklearen Sicherheit einer Opposition
hier im Deutschen Bundestag unwürdig
lassen Sie uns mit Hochdruck an der
Energiewende arbeiten weiter mit
Pragmatismus Handeln für zukünftige und
heutige Generation dankeschön
Christian kühn der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär von Steffi Lembke der
heute hier in der zweiten und dritten
Lesung gesprochen hat die Ministerin ist
zwar anwesend hat aber ja schon in der
ersten Lesung sich zu Wort gemeldet und
heute darauf verzichtet Julia Klöckner
jetzt für die CDU CSU sie ist spreche
für Wirtschaft
guten Morgen sehr geehrter frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Staatssekretär kühn dass
sie so gegen ihren Koalitionspartner FDP
hier austeilen hätte ich jetzt auch
nicht gedacht
und es gibt schon einen Unterschied sie
haben eben gesagt sie hätten bei der
Anhörung zugehört es gibt schon
Unterschied zwischen Zuhören und
Verstehen und dann auch noch böser
Unterstellung und ich verstehe es ja
dass gerade die Grünen ein Problem haben
das ist ihnen auch schwerfällt diesen
Gesetzentwurf heute einzubringen und
auch ihre Haltung zur Kernkraft zu
überarbeiten und der Realität stückweise
anzupassen das kann ich verstehen aber
was ich nicht verstehen kann ist dass
sie ihre Schmerzen und Windungen
abarbeiten an einer Opposition die mit
Fakten argumentiert und nicht mit
Ideologie so wie sie das hier machen ich
kann auch verstehen Liebe grünen wenn
man einen Jürgen Trittin in den Reinhard
der immer quer irgendwie im Stall steht
und sagt er lässt sich hier sein
Lebenswerk nicht in Zitat versauen da
sieht man natürlich dass die
kernkraftdebatte für sie zu einem
Selbstzweck geworden ist es geht hier
überhaupt nicht um die Frage wie können
wir diese Energiekrise die Menschen
Arbeitsplätze kostet die diesen Standort
in Deutschland nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig macht die die Menschen
abends mit sorgen ins Bett gehen lässt
steigender Energiepreise wie wir denen
jetzt her werden in einer Zeitenwende
das bedarf eigentlich auch eine neue
Justierung der politischen Sichtweisen
aber wenn jemand bei Ihnen sagt ich lass
mir mein politisches Lebenswerk nicht
zerstören oder Niedersachsen plakatiert
bei bei Atomkraft dann geht es ihnen
nicht mehr um die Sache nicht mehr um
die Menschen sondern um ihren
Gründungsmythos und das ist diesem Land
nicht gerecht das will ich Ihnen sehr
sehr deutlich sagen
und auch mit einem weiteren Märchen
möchte ich mal auflösen wir haben einen
Strombedarf jährlich etwa von 600
Terawattstunden in Deutschland die
Hälfte davon wird durch erneuerbare
Energien gedeckt und da kann ich sagen
Danke 16 Jahre Bundesregierung der CDU
und CSU und Herr kühn wenn sie dann mal
Richtung ja sie lachen jetzt ich weiß
dass Fakten ich weiß dass Fakten weh tun
und deshalb lachen sie ja heute auch
ihre große Ikone Greta Thunberg aus sie
haben ihr ja lange zugeklatscht aber
jetzt lachen Sie sie aus im übrigen
lachen sie auch die Experten ihre
gaspreiskommission aus sie lachen mit
ihren Lachen jetzt auch aus
Wirtschaftsweisen sie lachen mit ihrem
Lachen jetzt aus Studien der Uni
Erlangen die genau das besagen dass am
Ende der Energiepreis gesenkt werden
könnte und am Ende auch eine
Unabhängigkeit in Deutschland gesichert
werden könnte durch einen Remix es geht
doch nicht um Alles oder Nichts es geht
doch darum wie wir einen guten
Energie-Mix hinbekommen
Laufzeitverlängerung zwei Jahre länger
weil eines habe ich jetzt auch gelernt
im übrigen das war der Kollege Träger
der den Sekt schon kalt legt also nach
ihrer Lesart ist das ja so nach der
Ampel dass der Krieg sehr sicher am
15.4.2023 beendet sein wird dass sie das
Wissen ist hochinteressant und wenn sie
auch sagen dass an die Energiekrise
beendet sein wird jetzt ruft der reiner
in die Atomkraft wird beendet sein also
das ist ja schon eine hohe Form der
Dialektik der wir nicht mehr folgen
können Sie sagen auf der einen Seite
sie sagen auf der einen Seite die
Kernkraftnutzung ist so schlimm dass sie
ihren Kindern das nicht zumuten können
und es hätte nichts mit dem Krieg zu tun
Stichwort 15 vierter nächsten Jahres ja
dann müssen sie es ja wenn sie ihren
Kindern die Augen schauen wollen heute
doch beenden warum stimmen sie denn
heute überhaupt noch der Verlängerung zu
für umtreibt entweder sind es Fakten
oder ist Ideologie oder ist das
Machtwort des Kanzlers der heute nicht
hier sitzt bei einer so wichtigen Frage
[Applaus]
70 Mal haben sie dieses Wort genutzt
aber die ergebnisoffene Prüfung im
übrigen die ist ja so nicht gelaufen und
transparent auch nicht weil ein grüner
Staatssekretär den Passus im vermarkt
streichen ließ dass die CO2-Reduktion
mit AKW Laufzeitverlängerung um 25 bis
30 Millionen Tonnen CO2-Reduktion
beinhalten würde das heißt ihnen geht es
doch gar nicht mehr um den Klimaschutz
ihnen geht es doch nur noch um
parteiprogrammatik und dann nehmen sie
in Kauf dann nehmen Sie Doppelmoral in
Kauf und das muss ich sagen ist mehr als
fraglich denn sie endsolidarisieren sich
mit anderen Ländern in Europa uniper
steigen wir ein uniper baut
Kernkraftwerke in Schweden andere Länder
in Europa müssen teure Preise zahlen
ärmere Länder auch nur Deutschland nutzt
die eigenen Möglichkeiten nicht und
deshalb sage ich sehr klar wir haben
auch eine Verantwortung anderen
gegenüber wir wollen gefrecktes Gas
importieren selber hier nicht fördern
wir wollen Kernenergie importieren
selber hier nicht produzieren das ist
wegschieben das ist wie moderner
Kolonialismus und das haben die Grünen
zu verantworten und deshalb bin ich sehr
froh und damit schließe ich dass unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender heute da ist im
Vergleich zu FDP die das nicht ertragen
kann und hiermit gratuliere ich ihm sehr
herzlich zum heutigen Geburtstag
der Bundestag debattiert über das
Änderung die Änderung des Atomgesetzes
die drei AKWs in Deutschland sollen
nicht am 31.12 abgeschaltet werden
sondern jetzt erst am 15 April kommenden
Jahres und die nächste Rednerin in der
Debatte kommt von der SPD Nina Scheer
sie ist die Sprecherin für Klimaschutz
und Energie
ist auch etwas Besonderes
und ich höre gerade Friedrich Merz hat
heute Geburtstag der Fraktionschef der
CDU CSU und Julia Klöckner hatte ja
gerade hier im Öffentlichkeit gratuliert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen da jetzt hier
gerade noch mal auf die Koalitionäre
Geschlossenheit angespielt wurde Frau
Klöckner ich möchte sie mal daran
erinnern was wir bei der letzten Runde
2010 hier erleben mussten und auch im
Vorfeld von 2010 als
Schwarz-Gelb damals
Laufzeitverlängerungen um alles in der
Welt beschließen wollte und ein ganzes
Jahr gebraucht hat um über Prognos
errechnen zu lassen dass dies denn nötig
sei ich betone sei damals hatten sie
auch intern einen großen Konflikt es gab
damals einen baden-württembergischen
Ministerpräsidenten Herrn matthus der
öffentlich den damaligen CDU
Umweltminister zum Rücktritt
aufgefordert hatte weil ihm das nicht
gereicht hat dass Herr Röttgen nur vier
Jahre Laufzeitverlängerung wollte man
hörte bei ihm sehr deutlich raus dass
auch diese vier Jahre ein Zugeständnis
waren dass er an sich nicht die
Selbstständigkeit von
Laufzeitverlängerung sah und immer und
immer wieder wurde betont aus ihren
dreien man brauche dies aus
versorgungssicherheitsgründen weil die
Mengen nicht reichten dafür brauchte man
dann eben diese Studie ein Treppenwitz
war dann ja auch noch dass dann die
beteiligten Ministerien nebeneinander
standen diese prognosstudie in den in
den in die Kamera hielten Herr Röttgen
hatte ein offenkundig anderes Exemplar
kleiner Scherz beiseite aber ist das ist
das was 2010 zu Laufzeitverlängerung
geführt hatte und dann bekanntermaßen im
März 2011 Fukushima und nichts war
gewesen
man hat sich für den Ausstieg aus der
Rückabwicklung entschieden
und mit keiner Silbe mehr war irgendwie
erwähnenswert was denn zu dieser
komischen
rückwärtsgewandten Laufzeitverlängerung
geführt hatte wenn es gab diese Lücke
nicht die sich herbei reden
und jetzt sind wir sind wir zwölf Jahre
weiter wir haben massive Investitionen
der erneuerbare Energien getätigt leider
auf ihre Intervention hin sehr viel
langsamer als das mit dem Wunsch der SPD
gekommen wäre sehr viel langsamer wir
hatten im Jahr 2010 ungefähr 30
Milliarden Investitionen in erneuerbaren
Energien es war dann der absolute
Tiefpunkt im 2000 Jahr 2019 erreicht und
jetzt hatte sich dann etwas erholt aber
Sie müssen endlich mal eingestehen dass
das was sie mit der Atomenergie
öffentlich und auch in der
Erwartungshaltung verknüpfen die sie den
Menschen unterjubeln wollen dass das
bedeutet wir werden die Energiewende
verlangsamen das ist das eigentliche die
eigentliche Botschaft die sie mit ihrem
Gerede über Laufzeitverlängerungen die
ganze Zeit über wieder in die Welt
setzen es ist nachgewiesenermaßen so
dass in dem Moment wo Atomenergie im
Netz ist erneuerbare Energien verdrängt
werden und genau das war ja auch ein
Grund warum wir diese Frage mit dem
streckbetrieb auch sehr kritisch gesehen
haben denn es ist de facto so dass in
dem Moment wo Atome Energie im Netz ist
erneuerbare Energien kein Platz haben
wenn es eben zuletzt Engpässen kommt
wenn es zu Netz Engpässen kommt und das
ist leider immer wieder der Fall es ist
gerade wieder errechnet worden das in
Europa Laufzeitverlängerungen über das
was hier an europäischen Regelwerk
existiert Laufzeitverlängerung bedeuten
würden das 12% mehr erneuerbare Energien
aus dem Netz gedrängt würden das alles
ignorieren sie wenn sie weiterhin den
weiteren auf die Laufzeitverlängerung
setzen und natürlich ist es so dass
diese ganzen Gründe die ganzen Gründe
die auch schon immer gegen Atome Energie
gesprochen haben dass diese Gründe nach
wie vor Bestand haben auch das wird die
permanent von ihnen
unter den Teppich gekehrt es ist auch
schon von einigen meiner Vorredner
genannt worden alle hatten es im Gepäck
diese Argumente sind auch einfach nicht
aus der Welt zu schaffen es gibt in der
ganzen Welt kein einziges AKW und die
deutschen eingeschlossen was kriegs- und
krisensicher gebaut worden wären das ist
auch ein konnte einfach verschieben wird
von ihnen Frau Dr cher gestatten Sie
einen nein
zu nehmen sind es wird von ihnen einfach
verschwiegen dass natürlich die
Gesellschaft die Haftung übernimmt wenn
das nicht von dem Trabern übernommen
wird dieses ganze Modell von
Atomenergienutzung fußt darauf dass die
Gesellschaft die in das Ausfallrisiko
dieser Atomenergie Nutzung trägt und
zwar schon die ganze Zeit über wir haben
eine keine Betreiber wir haben eine
betreiberhaftung statt eine AKW bezogene
Haftung wir haben eine Haftungsgrenze im
Atomgesetz all dies sind
politische Entscheidungen gewesen um
überhaupt in eine Nutzung kommen zu
können die sich kostenseitig irgendwie
abbilden des wirtschaftlich irgendwie
abbilden lässt aber es ist eben auch an
der Zeit irgendwann zu sagen diese Dauer
suchventionierung die nur einen weiteren
Ausbau erneuerbare Energien im Wege
steht diese dauersubventionierung auch
versteckt muss endlich aufhören
und ich möchte auch einfach noch mal
einmal daran erinnern was wir in den
letzten Wochen hier entschieden haben
und wo wirklich der Fokus wenn es um
Energiesicherheit geht verstärkt drauf
gelenkt werden muss nämlich auf den
verstärkten Ausbau erneuerbaren Energien
und alleine in den letzten Wochen haben
wir mit dem dritten
energiesicherungsgesetz mit der
Überarbeitung desselben Ende September
noch mal ein erneuerbaren Energien
Booster beschlossen alleine das was wir
dort an
ausnutzbaren Mengen schon bestehender
schon installierter Anlagen beschlossen
haben an Erleichterung für eine
Auslastung der schon bestehenden Anlagen
ist mehr als das was jetzt im
streckbetrieb ermöglicht wird das wird
auch leicht unter den Teppich gekehrt
meine Zeit ist leider beendet ich danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
aus der afd-fraktion Rainer Kraft ja
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau Scheer
sie wiederholen hier einen erneut einen
Vorwurf der auch in der öffentlichen
Anhörung von vielen vermeintlichen
Experten geäußert worden ist dass Strom
der eine Strom den anderen irgendwie
blockieren würde also das sogenannte
kernkraftwerkstrom den Strom aus
sogenannten erneuerbaren Quellen
blockiert das ist erstens natürlich
nicht der Fall und zweitens ist wäre es
komplett umgesetzt ich denn das
erneuerbare Energien Gesetz kennt die
vorrangseinspeisung das heißt es ist per
Gesetz geregelt dass man immer eine
erzeugte Kilowattstunde aus sogenannten
erneuerbaren Energien ins Netz
eingespeist werden kann dass die
konventionellen heruntergefahren werden
müssen um Platz für die Aufnahme im Netz
dieser Kilowattstunde sogenannten
Erneuerbaren zu schaffen das heißt der
Effekt den Sie angesprochen haben und
den manche Experten in der öffentlichen
Anhörung haben vermuten wollen der ist
per Gesetz illegal den darf es gar nicht
geben außer unter der einzigen Ausnahme
dass wenn das Netz nämlich bereits mit
Energie aus sogenannten erneuerbar
gesättigt ist dass erst dann eine
Kilowattstunde aus sogenannten
Erneuerbaren abgelehnt werden kann vom
Netz über 1100
sogenannten kernkraftwerksturm voll wäre
defakte nicht existieren kann und darf
das wäre nämlich absolut ungesetzlich
danke schön Frau Dr schell möchten Sie
antworten
[Applaus]
Herr Dr Graf sie müssten es eigentlich
besser wissen
sie unterstellen
mir Unwahrheit bzw faktenlosigkeit und
wollen das mit ihrerseitiger
faktenlosigkeit Belegen das ist mit
Verlaub etwas erbärmlich ja sie wissen
ganz genau sie wissen ganz genau dass in
Deutschland sehr viel Windstrom und auch
in Teilen Photovoltaik-Strom inzwischen
schon mit steigender Tendenz abgeriegelt
wird und das hat ein Grund weil die
Netzkapazität genau dann nicht ausreicht
wenn es aufgrund der fluktuierenden
Eigenschaft von erneuerbaren Energien
nicht ausreicht deswegen brauchen wir ja
auch ein Umbau des Stromsystems der auf
die Eigenschaften der erneuerbaren
Energien Rücksicht nehmen dieser Umbau
der ist natürlich ein zentrales Element
der Energiewende und daran wird ja auch
unter Hochdruck gearbeitet was Sie
ansprechen mit dem Vorrang erneuerbaren
Energien das führt ja auch dazu dass wir
eine Entschädigung eben diesen
abgeregelten Strom haben sonst würde der
sich ja gar nicht rechtfertigen diese
Entschädigung die steht für den Vorrang
aber aus nicht Sicherheitsgründen findet
diese Abriegelung statt und wenn Sie das
Verleugnen dann haben sie noch mal einen
neuen Level an Fakten Verleugnung
erreicht das tut mir sehr leid für sie
Herr dopra
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion Dr
Michael Kaufmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin geschätzte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Abgeordnete der
vorliegende Entwurf des Atomgesetzes
greift viel zu kurz ist im Ergebnis aber
zu begrüßen interessant ist dass sie in
der Begründung auf genau jene Argumente
zurückgreifen die wir Ihnen in den
vergangenen Monaten immer wieder
vorgetragen haben
wir hätten wir hätten die nun anstehende
Entscheidung und damit ein gutes Stück
mehr Sicherheit für die Bürger also
schon viel früher haben können wenn sie
nicht auf beiden Ohren taub gewesen
werden nur weil die richtigen Argumente
von der AFD kommen
es es brauchte erst das Machtwort eines
Bundeskanzler um den zerstrittenen
Hühnerhaufen der Koalition wieder ein
Stück weit auf den Kurs der Vernunft zu
bringen
unabhängig von der geringen
Laufzeitverlängerung müssen wir aber die
Voraussetzungen schaffen damit unsere
Industrie die großen Chancen der
Kerntechnik nutzen kann deswegen haben
wir diesen Antrag gestellt
allerdings nach der Beratung im
Ausschuss frage ich Sie werte Kollegen
ob Sie unseren Antrag überhaupt gelesen
haben
quer durch alle Fraktionen wurde erklärt
dass in Deutschland keine Kernkraftwerke
mehr gebaut wurden das aber geht am Kern
unseres Antrags völlig vorbei wir
fordern darin die öffentliche Förderung
der kernenergieforschung damit uns in
Deutschland das damit verbundene
wirtschaftliche Potenzial nicht verloren
geht
denn auch wenn sie es noch nicht bemerkt
haben im Hinblick auf die Kernenergie
ist Deutschland ein Geisterfahrer in der
Welt rund 90 Reaktoren befinden sich
weltweit in Planung weitere 60 werden
gerade gebaut und das ist zwar nicht in
nicht entfernen Regionen sondern in
unseren Nachbarländern in Nachbarländern
wie Polen den Niederlanden und
Frankreich
und diese Kernkraftwerke in den
Nachbarländern können uns vor Strom
sperren und den Blackout retten
wir setzen uns mit unserem Antrag dafür
ein dass dieses enorme wirtschaftliche
Potenzial der deutschen Industrie nicht
verloren geht die Ideologie geleitet der
Forschungspolitik gibt sich hingegen
alle Mühe die Entwicklung neuer und
bessere Reaktortechnik in Deutschland zu
unattraktiv wie möglich zu machen grüne
Politik ist der größte Standort Nachteil
für den Forschungsstandort Deutschland
und wenn Sie nun darauf verweisen dass
Forschung an der Kernenergie in
Deutschland ja nicht verboten sei dann
ist das mit Verlaub einfach lächerlich
und das wissen sie auch
indem Sie unseren Antrag ablehnen
schaden sie den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und betreiben indirekt
Wirtschaftsforschung für die
Wirtschaftsförderung für die USA
Russland oder China danke
Michael Kaufmann war das für die AFD der
nächste Redner in der Debatte kommt von
der FDP Lukas Köhler der ist der
zuständige stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzende
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ich glaube in
so einer Debatte die wir führen und die
wir zu Recht ja auch sehr
emotional führen in diesem Hohen Haus
muss man sich verdeutlichen warum wir
überhaupt darüber sprechen warum es
nötig ist diese Debatte zu führen und
das ist nicht weil wir die große Debatte
die müssen wir auch führen aber was
nicht weil wir die große Debatte über
die Zukunft der Energieversorgung in
Deutschland führen sondern es ist ganz
klar weil Wladimir Putin einen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine führt
und gleichzeitig ein energiekrieg gegen
uns gegen Europa und es ist nötig es ist
nötig jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass all das
was wir tun können um über den Winter zu
kommen auch getan wird und das ist der
Grund warum diese Debatte heute hier
geführt wird
das ist der Grund für dieses Gesetz
keine Diskussion kein ideologischer
Streit darüber ob wir jetzt
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen lassen oder
nicht sondern nur die Notwendigkeit über
diesen Winter zu kommen und das so
sicher wie es geht und das erlaubt
dieses Gesetz das hier vorgelegt wird
und ich bin froh darüber es ist ein
guter Tag für Deutschland weil wir dafür
sorgen dass Unternehmen
die Sicherheit haben über den Winter mit
ausreichend Energie zu kommen weil
Frankreich seine Atomkraftwerke nicht im
Griff hat weil wir zu wenig Gas haben
weil wir Probleme mit der Netzstabilität
haben und auch ja weil wir dafür sorgen
müssen dass die Preise im Strombereich
nicht nur durch einen strompreisdeckel
gesenkt werden sondern auch dadurch dass
wir alle Kapazitäten nutzen die wir zur
Verfügung haben
Herr Dr Köhler gestatten Sie eine Frage
oder Zwischenbemerkung aus der
afd-fraktion danke nein nein danke
die Diskussion die wir hier führen und
das ist das Wesentliche ist in einer
Situation entstanden in der Gas nicht
verstromt werden sollte unter keinen
Umständen weil wir müssen Gas sparen wir
müssen über diesen Winter kommen indem
wir so wenig Gas wie möglich nutzen die
Situation über das kommende Jahr und so
sieht es im Moment aus ist aber eine
andere wir haben LNG Kraft Kapazitäten
die wir ordentlich ausgebaut haben wir
haben eine neue Infrastruktur wir
importieren mehr Gas und ja die Hoffnung
besteht auch immer noch dass Frankreich
seine Stromversorgung wieder in den
Griff bekommt und deswegen sieht das
nächste Jahr anders aus und deswegen ist
es richtig jetzt über den 15.4 zu
sprechen deswegen ist es völlig korrekt
darüber nachzudenken wie kommen wir über
diesen Zeitraum über die kalte Zeit des
kommenden Jahres und da kein Gas zu
nutzen um Strompreise zu senken um für
Netzstabilität zu sorgen und es ist auch
richtig darüber zu sprechen wie wir 23
24 weitermachen aber da ist im Moment
die Antwort eindeutig Kohle und Gas und
ja auch das ist keine einfache Debatte
zum Glück ist aus klimapolitischer Sicht
der Schaden nicht so groß weil der
europäische Emissionshandel das ganze
regelt aber natürlich bedeutet diese
laufende Diskussion auch eine Debatte
darüber wie sieht die Stromversorgung in
Zukunft aus weil wir heute doch jetzt
schon wissen dass der alte Deal den wir
mal mit der Gesellschaft mit der
Wirtschaft geschlossen haben wir setzen
auf einen massiven Einstieg in
erneuerbare Energien und sorgen für eine
Grundversorgung in der deutschen
Energiewirtschaft durch Gas erst durch
Erdgas und dann durch Wasserstoff dass
dieser Deal so nicht funktionieren wird
denn das ist das Problem denn das
Problem ist doch dass wir günstiges
Pipeline Gas aus Russland nie wieder in
diesem Maß beziehen werden wie wir es
bisher getan haben und das ist auch
richtig so weil wir nicht abhängig sein
können aus anderen Quellen und wenn wir
dafür sorgen können dass der lng-preis
so niedrig ist dann funktioniert auch
die Diskussion aber
um die Energieversorgung in Zukunft
deutlich die Energieversorgung der
Zukunft Deutschlands sicherzustellen
werden wir jetzt dafür sorgen müssen
dass wir zum einen Debatte über den
Strommarkt führen eine Debatte darüber
wie sieht eigentlich eine Welt aus die
fast nur noch aus erneuerbaren Energien
besteht auch mit hohen wasserstoffkosten
und eine Debatte darüber wie kriegen wir
eigentlich ausreichend Gas um dahin zu
kommen und diese Debatte das ist das
eigentliche Wesentliche was wir jetzt
führen müssen die Debatte jetzt das zu
tun was nötig ist was richtig ist das
ist absolut korrekt
und ja der Not die Notwendigkeit
günstige Strompreise zu haben besteht
nicht nur für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sondern sie besteht auch insbesondere
für all diejenigen die wie wir wollen
dass dieses Land klimaneutral wird denn
wir werden es nicht hinbekommen
Klimaneutralität durch die durch
dekarbonisiert durch die
Industrialisierung zu erzeugen sondern
wir werden dafür sorgen müssen dass
Wirtschaftswachstum und der die
Reduktion von CO2 miteinander
einhergehen und dazu brauchen wir
günstige Energie
die Herausforderung vor der wir aber
gerade stehen ist dass wir enorme
Investitionen brauchen wir brauchen aber
auch gleichzeitig enorme
planungsbeschleunigung ich glaube das
ist die Debatte die wir als nächstes in
diesem Bundestag führen müssen wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir in
Deutschland schneller werden mit
Infrastruktur mit energieausbau und ja
wir tun heute was nötig ist aber wir
werden morgen dafür sorgen dass wir das
tun was weiterhin richtig ist vielen
Dank
Lukas Köhler war das für die FDP
aus der afd-fraktion hat Herr bistron
frau Präsidentin vielen vielen Dank für
diese kurze Intervention lieber Herr
Kollege sie haben Ihren Vortrag mit
einer Falschbehauptung eröffnet also
bitte
wir führen hier diese Diskussion nicht
deswegen weil tausende Kilometer
entfernt von uns ein Krieg stattfindet
wir führen diese Diskussion weil die
Bundesregierung erstmal aus der
Atomkraft ausgestiegen ist weil 2011 und
da waren sie FDP mit an der Regierung
mit beteiligt weil hier ein Beschluss
gefasst wurde weil in Fukushima ein ein
Atomunfall war wo Menschen wo Menschen
ertrunken sind wegen einer Tsunamiwelle
da ist niemand ein Radioaktivität
gestorben aber hier wurde Panik geschürt
vor Atomkraft ja ich meine das Risiko
das in Deutschland eine Tsunamiwelle
drüber schwappt ist relativ gering nicht
aber sie haben trotzdem den Ausstieg
beschlossen sie haben beschlossen dass
der Strom subst erklärt wird durch Gas
wir haben dann auf Gaskraftwerke
umgestiegen harten günstige
Lieferverträge von Russland langfristige
Verträge diese kippen sie wiederum das
in alles politische Entscheidungen das
sind alles Falsche politische
Entscheidungen und ich verstehe schon
dass sie sich da aus der Verantwortung
rausziehen wollen als FDP aber die
Wahrheit bleibt einfach eine andere der
Krieg ist nicht daran Schuld schuld
daran sind ihre falschen politischen
Entscheidungen
Herr Dr Köhler möchten Sie antworten
[Applaus]
Liebe Kollege ich habe noch versucht die
Frage zu entdecken aber
die zweifelhafte Verhältnis der AFD zu
Russland ist ja bekannt und dass sie
nicht akzeptieren können dass das
Problem vor der wir gerade stehen
deswegen entsteht weil eine politische
Entscheidung getroffen wurde und zwar
nicht hier im Haus sondern Flon Wladimir
Putin dieses Land anzugreifen der ist
dazu geführt hat dass Wladimir Putin
versucht diese Energiekrise dafür zu
nutzen selber zu erzeugen und dafür zu
nutzen dass dieses Land vor die Hunde
geht und dass wir uns mit aller Kraft
der demokratischen Parteien in diesem
Haus dagegen stemmen das ist mir klar
dass sie das nicht akzeptieren können
aber es ist traurig es ist traurig dass
ihre Fraktion darauf hofft dass dieser
Winter dazu führen wird das ist uns
schlecht geht weil sie sich politisch
davon erhoffen dass es ihnen gut geht
was ist das denn für eine Absurdität
sich hier hinzustellen und zu sagen dass
dieser Krieg nicht dafür verantwortlich
ist ist eine Absurdität der Geschichte
und erklärt sich leider nur dass sie
völlig verloren sind in ihrer
politischen Ausrichtung und dass sie
ganz dringen ihr Verhältnis zu Wladimir
Putin und zu Russland überdenken sollten
wenn sie das hier als Argument vorführen
es tut mir leid
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Bernhard Hermann
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
während 86 nach Tschernobyl die kleine
Tochter von Harald Ebner keinen Frühling
erlebte ließ man uns als 20-jährige
Grundwehrdienstleistende durch die
brandenburgischen wälderrobben
wir sammelten Pilze
die Atomlobbyisten aller politischen
Systeme waren sie schon immer
erschreckend einig verharmlost
verschwiegen und verantwortlich
aber mit dieser Erfahrung in die
Gegenwart
am Mittwoch ging der größte schwedische
Atomreaktor und planmäßig vom Netz heute
vor einer Woche hat die französische
Atomaufsichtsbehörde das Hochfahren des
Reaktors kattenorm 1 untersagt defekte
Schweißnähte gefährdeten die nukleare
Sicherheit nur mal zwei von unzähligen
Beispielen diesen Jahres die eins ganz
klar zeigen Atomkraftwerke sind keine
zuverlässige stabile Energiequelle
in Frankreich sieht man die Folgen
atomfreundlich Energiepolitik mehr als
die Hälfte der Kraftwerksleistung fehlt
seit Monaten am Netz die Strompreise
sind dort deutlich höher als hier in
Deutschland auch zu Stunde übrigens bei
uns drücken viel Wind und Sonnenstrom
den Großhandelspreis na klar dass das
einigen weh tut und nicht gefällt
trotzdem aber
oder eben deshalb halten einige
Ideologen weiter an der Meer
zuverlässiger günstiger Atome mit AG
fest und verkaufen Sie dann das
klimafreundliche Brücke zu einer
Energiewelt mit 100% erneuerbaren dabei
gehört die Atomkraft ebenso wie Fracking
zur alten Welt konventioneller Energie
ist eben keine Brücke in die neue Welt
sie ist ein Brückenpfeiler auf Sumpf
gebaut
der Atomkraftwerke sind unflexibel
können die Produktion nicht an Verbrauch
und volatile Erzeugung aus Sonne und
Wind anpassen sie verstopfen die Netze
zwingend dazu erneuerbare abzuschalten
für uns grüner ist klar der Atomausstieg
ist nötig und daran rütteln wir nicht
neue Brennstäbe mit neuem Atommüll gibt
es mit uns definitiv nicht
aber
der Energiekrise begegnen wir mit allen
sinnvoll verfügbaren Maßnahmen gerade in
diesem Winter besteht die Gefahr dass es
über begrenzte Zeit zu kritischen
netzsituationen kommen könnte die
geordnetes abschalten erfordern könnten
geringer übrigens als anderswo auch in
Westeuropa der Stresstest hat gezeigt
dass die süddeutschen LKWs einen sehr
begrenzten Beitrag leisten können die
Situation zu entspannen in Abwägung
zwischen nuklearer Sicherheit und
Energieversorgungssicherheit halte ich
daher deren streckbetrieb für fachlich
vertretbar das trifft für das AKW
Emsland nicht zu in Norddeutschland gibt
es genügend andere Kraftwerkskapazität
der dort fachlich für mich nicht
nachvollziehbare streckbetrieb ist ein
sehr schwer hinnehmbarer politischer
Kompromiss das wird mich nach
gewissenhafter Abwägung jedoch nicht
davon abhalten den Regierungsantrag
zuzustimmen
denn das wichtigste was dieser eben auch
enthält und explizit vom Kanzler
bestätigt wurde es wird keinen neuen
Brennelemente geben und am 15 April 23
werden die verbleibenden AKWs endgültig
abgeschaltet und unsverzüglich
rückgebaut
Herr Bundeskanzler vor allem auch sie
stehen hier im Wort vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR Andreas Lenz
Andreas Lenze Sprecher für Energie und
Nachhaltigkeit der Unionsfraktion
en sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen es ist schon eine
besondere Episode der ampelpolitik die
wir im Kontext der Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke erleben zunächst wurden
vom Ministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz sowie vom Umweltministerium
Prüfungen nach dem Motto durchgeführt
weil nicht sein kann was nicht sein darf
für rücken Sie nicht unser ideologisches
Weltbild unsere Meinung steht bereits
fest vor der Prüfung des Sachverhalts
wurden wieder besseres Wissens
Stellungnahmen vorformuliert ohne die
fachebenen einzubeziehen ohne den Rat
und die Expertise der
Kraftwerksbetreiber zu berücksichtigen
ohne die Studienlage zu berücksichtigen
ohne auf den Rat von Fachbeamten zu
hören wurde mehr als ein Vermerk
erstellt indem dann auch den 100 stand
ein weiter Betrieb sein nicht sei nicht
zu empfehlen inhaltliche Punkte zum sehr
wohlmöglichen sicheren Weiterbetrieb CO2
zu co2-minderungseffekten zu
gaspar-effekten zu
kais-dämpfungseffekten wurden
schlichtweg unterschlagen und
ausgeblendet und das das ist im höchsten
Maße unseriös meine Damen und Herren
tricksen und tricksen und Täuschen
leugnen und Lügen unterschlagen und das
Unterdrücken von Kritik es drängt sich
der Eindruck auf das in den Ministerien
so gearbeitet wurde das Ganze das Ganze
garniert mit andauernden Aussagen wie
beispielsweise wir haben wir hätten
keinen Stromproblem oder es würden durch
einen Weiterbetrieb nur marginale Mengen
Gas eingespart werden eine
ergebnisoffene Prüfung
zuzusagen und sie dann nur vorzugaukeln
das ist schon ganz schön dreist meine
Damen und Herren und
und
Herr Habeck ist eben doch nicht der
andere der ehrlichere Politiker alpine
sich ja gerne darstellt lügen haben
kurze Laufzeiten so kann man den
Sachverhalt gut zusammenfassen meine
Damen und Herren
und dann
und dann kam eine bestellte
richtlinienentscheidung aus dem
Kanzleramt um die Basis der Parteien
sowohl der grünen als auch der FDP quasi
zu besänftigen das ist eine riesige
Mogelpackung meine Damen und Herren
schaut man sich an was der Weiterbetrieb
bis zum 15 April beinhaltet dann ist
beim Kraftwerk Emsland aber auch bei den
anderen ein massiver Abfall der Leistung
und damit der produzierten Strommenge
verbunden das bedeutet schreckbetrieb in
Emsland ist es so dass von jetzt 1,3 die
wie Leistung auf im April dann nur noch
0,6g die Leistung entsprechend die
Leistung reduziert werden wird das
Problem ist dass eben keine neuen
Brennstäbe bestellt werden diese sind
aber notwendig denn es wird auch
2023/24 einen Winter geben und auch da
wird Strom gebraucht werden sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren und
und deshalb müssen wir jetzt bestmöglich
da darauf vorbereitet sein und
entsprechend auch die Brennstäbe
bestellt werden und ich muss ganz offen
sagen ich bin ich bin gespannt wann die
FDP eigentlich merkt dass sie wirklich
die allerletzten sind die sich hier
durchgesetzt haben sie lassen sich doch
hier gerade von den Grünen aus
ideologischen Gründen verhaften sie
können heute gerne ihrem eigenen
Vorschlag zustimmen wenn Sie unseren
Vorschlag zustimmen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
brauchen nach wie vor jede
Kilowattstunde die Lage ist nach wie vor
Ernst mehr Strom mehr Strom aus
Kernkraft führt zu weniger verschwunden
Gas zu weniger CO2-Emissionen zu
sinkenden Preisen und leistet einen
Beitrag zur Versorgungssicherheit und
zur Netzstabilität auch über den 15
April hinaus herzlichen Dank
Andreas Lenz war das für die CDU CSU
der nächste Redner war mal in der
afd-fraktion ist dort ausgetreten jetzt
also fraktionslos Robert Falle hat hier
das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die Ampel will
drei Kernkraftwerke jetzt drei Monate
weiterlaufen lassen sie haben
offensichtlich Angst vor dem ersten
Protest der Bürger sobald der erste
Blackout Auftritt die Grünen
transformationsideologen bestehen auf
der endgültigen Abschaltung weil sie
Argumenten in keiner Weise mehr
zugänglich sind
die Nationalistin Ulrike Herrmann hat es
mit verblüffender Ehrlichkeit auf den
Punkt gebracht ich zitiere man muss sich
klar machen dass Klimaschutz den totalen
Umbau bedeutet da bleibt kein Stein auf
dem anderen dann ist klar dass es das
grüne Wachstum nicht geben wird sondern
was wir hier haben werden ist grüne
schrumpfen wir müssen raus aus dem
Kapitalismus Zitat Ende ihnen geht es
nicht um den Klimawandel und das Klima
sondern um den totalen Umbau weg von
einer freiheitlichen sozialen
Marktwirtschaft hier zu einer CO2
gesteuerten
Misswirtschaft und schrumpfwirtschaft
und Mangelwirtschaft
alle Verfahren der Energieerzeugung die
eine industrielle Produktion ermöglichen
sind in Deutschland von ihnen diskutiert
diskreditiert worden übrigens bleiben
nur noch Windkraftanlagen und
Solarpaneele die für die industrielle
Produktion nicht taugen wenn es ihnen um
CO2 ginge dann wäre das
co2-abscheideverfahren nicht verboten
dann wären die e-fuels zugelassen dann
würden Kernkraftwerke dauerhaft
weiterlaufen bis in der ganzen Welt der
Fall ist sie wollen mit der Brechstange
zurück ins vorindustrielle Zeitalter ins
Mittelalter kein motorisierten
Individualverkehr keine
Einfamilienhäuser keine Flugreisen kein
Fleisch Verzehr kein Silvesterfeuerwerk
Verbote statt Freiheit sehr geehrter
Herr Habeck sie haben uns bezüglich der
Energieversorgung belogen und betrogen
tre sie endlich ab
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Jakob blankenburg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben in
dieser Woche sehr intensiv über das Für
und Wieder der Verlängerung der
AKW-Laufzeiten gesprochen und zwar nicht
nur hier im Plenum sondern auch im
Petitionsausschuss im Rahmen einer
öffentlichen Anhörung mit zahlreichen
Expertinnen und Experten aus der
Wissenschaft und im Umweltausschuss und
nach diesen vielfältigen Beratungen
stehen wir heute hier um zu entscheiden
wie lange die drei noch am Netz
befindlichen Atomkraftwerke Emsland Isa
2 und Neckarwestheim 2 weiterbetrieben
werden entweder wie von der
Unionsfraktion vorgeschlagen mindestens
zwei Jahre länger also bis Ende 2024 mit
einem Hintertürchen für weitere
Laufzeitverlängerung und wenn sie
ehrlich werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union dann würden Sie
sagen dass es das ist was sie eigentlich
wollen dieses Hintertürchen oder wie von
der Regierungskoalition vorgeschlagen
für dreieinhalb Monate bis zum 15 April
des nächsten Jahres
meine Meinung dazu ist klar wir schaffen
mit dem AKW streckbetrieb über den wir
heute reden bis zum 15 April ein
weiteres Sicherheitsnetz für die
Energieversorgung auch wenn wir
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass wir es
nicht brauchen werden aber mit dieser
Entscheidung zum temporären
Weiterbetrieb der übernimmt die
Regierungskoalition Verantwortung in
schwierigen Zeiten in denen Energie
sorgen Bürgerinnen und Bürger genauso
umtreiben wie die zahlreichen kleinen
und großen Betriebe in diesem Land
und zu Recht haben wir uns diese
Entscheidung nicht leicht gemacht denn
es ging um eine sehr grundsätzliche
Abwägung zwischen den Aspekten
Sicherheit Gesundheitsschutz
Versorgungssicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
von Energie die Aufgabe einer
verantwortungsvollen Regierung ist es
all diese Aspekte miteinander in
Einklang zu bringen und das ist uns
gelungen wir halten aber Thomas stieg
fest wie wir es auch 2021 im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben wir
kaufen keine neuen Brennstäbe wir nutzen
vorhandene Ressourcen zu
Energieerzeugung komplett aus konkret
holen wir noch das letzte bisschen
Energie aus den in den AKW eingesetzten
Brennstäben heraus
und und wir behalten uns mit dem
zeitlich sehr begrenzten
akw-streckbetrieb die Sicherheitsrisiken
und Entsorgungsfragen der Nutzung der
Atomkraft im Blick wir gehen als
Koalition eben nicht nach dem Prinzip wo
gehobelt wird da fallen Späne vor wie
das während der Expertin Anhörung von
einem Sachverständigen der Union als
gangbarer Weg betrachtet wurde für uns
ist ganz klar die Nutzung der Atomkraft
ist und bleibt riskant
als als Regierungskoalition der
übernehmen wir außerdem Verantwortung
beim Thema Energiepreise der Strompreis
dämpfende Effekt des akw-streckbetriebs
ist das ist das Lieblingsargument der
Unionsfraktion für ihren Gesetzentwurf
aber es ist fraglich ob der AKW
Weiterbetrieb überhaupt zu spürbaren
Effekten beim Strompreis führt das haben
hat auch die öffentliche Anhörung am
Mittwoch noch mal intensiv ergeben
vielleicht hätten da einige Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aus der Unionsfraktion noch
mal besser aufpassen sollen
die oder anwesend sein auch ein guter
Tipp die Aussagen der Wissenschaft über
die absenkende Wirkung des AKW
Weiterbetriebs auf den Strompreis die
unterscheiden sich stark und werden vor
dem Hintergrund unterschiedliche
Annahmen getroffen aber was sie vereint
sie sind nicht groß genug um wirkliche
Entlastung bei Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sowie Unternehmen beim Strompreis zu
sorgen das Preisargument ist also ein
vorgeschobenes Argument und das zu
fordern was sie auch schon vor dem
abscheulichen Angriff Kriegs Russland
auf die Ukraine und der daraufhin
folgenden Energiekrise gefordert haben
den mehrjährigen Weiterbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke was wir mit Blick auf
bezahlbare Energie wirklich brauchen
sind grundlegende Veränderungen auf der
systemischen Ebene und genau diese
systemischen Ebene die gehen wir jetzt
an und bei Bürgerinnen und Bürgern sowie
Unternehmen auch für kurzfristige
Entlastung zu sorgen da bringen wir
schon jetzt konkrete Instrumente auf den
Weg die Strom- und gaspreisbremsen
werden kommen und es wird gezielte
entlastungszahlungen geben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist geht
uns als Regierungskoalition also darum
dass wir genug in der das genug Energie
zur Verfügung steht und auch darum dass
sie dass sie bezahlbar bleibt beides
werden wir auch nach dem 15 April
sicherstellen wenn das letzte
Atomkraftwerk abgeschaltet ist das ist
es was es braucht nicht das ein
weiterköcheln der Diskussion über den
Atomausstieg in den Winter in den
Wintermonaten Entscheidung wieder
aufzuschnüren bringt und bringt uns
energiepolitisch nicht weiter nur der
beschleunigte Ausbau Erneuerbaren
erneuerbare Energien hilft uns
nachhaltig bei der Überwindung der
Energiekrise frau Präsidentin letzter
Satz liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lass
sie uns hier und heute nach gründlicher
Abwägung eine Entscheidung über eine
befristeten streckbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke treffen und uns dann
wieder den anderen dringenden
dringenderen Fragen zu wenden vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
Blankenburg war das für die SPD der
vorletzte Redner hier ist Fabian
gramling von der
cdu/csu und danach wird es dann drei
namentliche Abstimmung hier im Plenum
geben aber zunächst fahren wir an
grammling Herr Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in diesen Tagen
findet die Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten
statt 190 Nationen reden über den
Klimaschutz und wir haben Deutschen
Bundestag bisher uns diesem Thema noch
nicht gewidmet ganz im Gegenteil heute
letzter Tagesordnungspunkt werden wir
darüber sprechen ich persönlich finde
das beschämend und wenn wir
und wenn wir über das Klima reden wenn
wir über Klimaschutz reden dann müssen
wir natürlich die erneuerbaren Energien
ausbauen und da gibt es diverse Studien
die besagen dass wir ab 2027 einen
Großteil der Strom des Strombedarfs
überneubare Energien decken können aber
wieso häufig in Studien dass der Fall
ist muss man natürlich diese Studien
auch ganz genau lesen und genau
hinschauen und wenn wir diese Studien
genau anschaut dann sieht man die
Annahme dass der Erneuerbaren
energienbereich die
ausbaugeschwindigkeit vor vierfacht
werden muss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vervierfacht werden muss und
wenn wir jetzt mal wenn man jetzt mal
die aktuelle Situation anschaut wie ist
es denn bei den erneuerbaren Energien
schreien sie weniger das besser für den
Blutdruck wenn man mal schaut wie die
aktuelle Situation bei den in der
Branche der neubahnenergien ausschaut
dann sieht man dass man das eine
Schockstarre vorherrscht warum auf der
einen Seite der Krieg auf der einen
Seite aber auch ihre Diskussion über die
gewinnabgabe über die Gewinnabschöpfung
Planungssicherheit hier für die
Unternehmen fehlanzeige
von der frage ich mich ob es
verantwortbar ist in einer Zeit wo wir
nicht wissen wie schnell kriegen wir
denn die erneuerbaren Energien ausgebaut
in einer Zeit wo wir nicht wissen wie
viel Gas haben wir denn im nächsten Jahr
oder im übernächsten Jahr sie haben also
selbst erkannt dass man die
Kohlekraftwerke hochfahren muss aber ich
frage mich ob es vernünftig ist in einer
solchen Zeit in einer Energiekrise gegen
den Expertenrat nicht nur gegen den
Willen der CDU und bisschen der FDP
sondern gegen den Willen und gegen die
Empfehlung des expertenrades die letzten
drei Kernkraftwerke Mitte April 23
abzuschalten ich halte das nicht
verantwortbar
und wir reden wir reden auf der einen
Seite über Versorgungssicherheit wir
reden aber auch über das Klima Stichwort
Klimakonferenz in Ägypten und wenn man
da mal schaut was die Beamten im
Bundesumweltministerium
niedergeschrieben haben bzw eigentlich
haben sie ja nicht wieder geschrieben
niedergeschrieben weil es wurde wieder
rausgestrichen also es ist ja relativ
ist ja die Frage die sich jetzt deuten
möchten aber wenn wenn Beamte im
umweltbundes Umweltministeriums sagen
dass ein Weiterbetrieb der drei
verbleibt verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke ab
2024 zu einer Reduzierung der CO2
treibhauskarte führen können von bis zu
30 Millionen Tonnen dann frage ich mich
und dann stelle ich mir die Frage ob sie
heute bewusst im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes die Probleme von morgen weiter
befeuern dass sie morgen sich darüber
beklagen können liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der ampelfraktion Herr
gramleben gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung aus
der Fraktion der Grünen ich würde gerne
weitermachen
auch deshalb weil wir im März viel
gehört haben was alles nicht geht im Mrs
im Winter helfen keine Kernkraftwerke im
Mercedes ist die Laufzeitverlängerung
ist nicht möglich weil es gibt
Sicherheitsbedenken im Mercedes die der
Weiterbetrieb sein nicht möglich weil
die Mitarbeiter nicht vorhanden sind
heute stellen wir fest dass es möglich
ist und es ist auch heute möglich
Trennelemente zu bestellen und diese
predelemente im Frühsommer 23
einzusetzen es liegt an ihrem Willen
lieber ampelregierung und verstehen Sie
mich da nicht falsch aber wenn Sie heute
eine Beschaffung ablehnen da müsst ihr
auch morgen die volle Verantwortung für
das nicht tun fragen
und wir haben und wir haben viel über
Ergebnis auf eine Prüfung gesprochen wir
haben viel auch über den prüfvermehr
gesprochen der er dann auch wieder
irgendwie zusammengestrichen wurde aber
über den eigenen schildbücher
bürgerstreicht haben wir noch nicht
gesprochen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie möchten heute beschließen
dass die Kernkraftwerke Mitte April 23
abgeschaltet werden auf der anderen
Seite hat aber das
Wirtschaftsministerium geplant Ende
April zwei Wochen später den Stresstest
für den Winter 23 24 es vorzulegen ich
halte das als unseriös ich halte das als
für unwillkürlich und ich hatte das als
unanständig wir fordern sie auf legen
Sie den Stresstest früher vor und folgen
Sie unserem Antrag und lassen Sie die
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen vielen Dank
so und die letzte Rednerin hier in
dieser Debatte zum Änderung des
Atomgesetzes ist
Lina Seidel von der SPD sie ist im
Ausschuss für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz
Blick zurückwerfen einen Blick zurück in
das Jahr 2000 bzw 2002 wo die damalige
rot-grüne Landesregierung den Ausstieg
aus der Atomkraft in Deutschland
beschlossen alle dann ein Blick zurück
in das Jahr 2010 und diese Entscheidung
durch die damalige schwarz-gelbe
Bundesregierung zurückgenommen wurde und
dann ein Jahr später
2011 wieder zurückgeworfen wurde der
Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg aus dem
Ausstieg und wenn ich Ihren Antrag jetzt
folgenden hätten wir noch ein viertes
aus dem Ausstieg müsste man hinten
dranhängen
2011 haben sie diese Entscheidung
getroffen hat dieses Haus diese
Entscheidung getroffen in einem breiten
Konsens gesellschaftlich und politisch
als Reaktion auf die Nuklearkatastrophe
in Fukushima es gab die klare politische
Einigung und der klare politische und
gesellschaftliche Konsens die Atomkraft
hat in keine Zukunft
und dabei bleibt es wir halten auch mit
dieser Entscheidung heute am
Atomausstieg fest es werden keine neuen
Brennelemente angekauft und es werden
gleichzeitig umfangreiche Maßnahmen zum
Energiesparen durchgesetzt und gut durch
diesen Winter zu kommen damit zeigen wir
einmal mehr wir übernehmen Verantwortung
in keinen ganz einfachen Zeichen wir
zeigen wir sichern uns ab für eine
Extremsituation wenn vorhandene
stromressourcen gegebenenfalls nicht
überall im Land
ausreichen aber wir legen auch ein
finales Ausstiegsdatum fest nämlich den
15 April 2023 und es gibt und es gibt
auch gute Gründe warum wir das tun und
darum wir nicht eine Verlängerung über
dieses Datum hinaus anstreben erstens
der Beitrag der Atomkraft zur
Energiesicherheit und zur Bezahlbarkeit
von Energie ist gering RKW können kein
Gas ersetzen sondern sie er Strom und
mein Kollege Blankenburg hat schon
gesagt der Effekt auf den Strompreis ist
zumindest mal fraglich sicher ist dass
das so gering ist dass es nicht wirklich
zu Entlastung von Verbrauchern
Verbrauchern kommt diese Entlastung
setzen wir in der Koalition mit den
Strom und gaspreisbremsen besser durch
zweitens
der eine Verlängerung würde den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren weiter behindern
erneuerbare sind in Kombination mit
Speichertechnologien viel flexibler als
gernkraftwerke sie sind unsere Zukunft
wir sollten hier keine Ressourcen
rausziehen sondern wir sollten auf den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren setzen 3
Atomkraft kommt mit hohen Risiken die
Entscheidung von Schwarz-Gelb damals
2011 war ja eine Reaktion auf eine
solche Nuklearkatastrophe in Fukushima
und wir können brauchen nur in die
Ukraine gerade gucken da sehen wir die
besorgniserregende Situation von
Kernkraftwerken und viertens Atomkraft
ist das Gegenteil von Nachhaltigkeit und
Generationengerechtigkeit wir
produzieren seit Jahrzehnten atomaren
Müll von dem wir heute nicht wissen wo
wir ihn entsorgen das ist eine Hypothek
für alle nachkommenden Generationen und
Atom benötigt unglaubliche Mengen von
Wasser angesichts des Klimawandels keine
gute Idee wer sich das anguckt der guckt
mal im Sommer nach Frankreich wo viele
Kernkraftwerke auch wegen der
Trockenheit abgeschaltet werden mussten
wir treffen heute also eine kluge
Entscheidung in einer schwierigen
Situation und und das ist der Blick nach
vorne wir müssen wegkommen von dieser
Diskussion wir müssen hinkommen zum
schnellen Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zur
schnellen Entwicklung und Nutzung von
intelligenten Speichertechnologien das
ist die Zukunft der Strom- und der
Energieversorgung in Deutschland vielen
Dank
so das war's die Debatte und nun hören
wir mal der Bundestagspräsidentin zu
Bärbel Bass es gibt gleich drei Namibia
zunächst einige Hinweise zum
abstimmungsverlauf zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt werden wir drei
namentliche Abstimmung durchführen die
jeweils für 10 Minuten eröffnet werden
wir beginnen mit der namentlichen
Abstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung es folgt dann die
namentliche Abstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der cdu/csu
und schließlich die namentliche
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der AFD nach
der Schließung der ersten beiden
namentlichen Abstimmung unterbreche ich
jeweils kurz die Sitzung um die
Abstimmung inhaltlich voneinander zu
trennen und um die Urnen auszutauschen
die Beratung zur Tagesordnungspunkt 33
beginnt erst nach Schließung der dritten
namentlichen Abstimmung
wir kommen nun zu den Abstimmungen
Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes dazu liegen mir mehrere
persönliche Erklärungen nach § 31
unserer Geschäftsordnung vor der
Ausschuss für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf den Drucksachen
4.357 und
4423 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
4217 anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die
dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um
das Handzeichen
das sind die Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und die FDP wer stimmt
dagegen dass die Fraktion der Linken
einige Abgeordnete aus der Fraktion der
Grünen Bündnis 90 grüne die
cdu/csu-fraktion
dagegen
Enthaltung
die afd-fraktion Enthaltung
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen
wir kommen jetzt zur dritten Beratung
und Schlussabstimmung die Fraktion DIE
LINKE hat namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme in der
westlobby ca 10 Minuten Zeit ich
erinnere daran dass nach der
namentlichen Abstimmung die Sitzung kurz
unterbrochen wird ich bitte die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer die
Plätze einzunehmen ich bekomme das
Signal das ist erfolgt
dann eröffne ich hiermit die erste
namentliche Schlussabstimmung
ja meine Damen und Herren jetzt gilt es
hier für die
Bundestagsabgeordneten zunächst einmal
über den Gesetzentwurf der
ampelregierung abzustimmen der Entwurf
eines 19 Gesetzes zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes soll nach dem Willen der
Ampel auch der letzte sein nämlich dort
ist festgeschrieben dass die drei
Atomkraftwerke die noch am Netz sich
befinden weiterlaufen sollen über den
31.12 dieses Jahres hinaus aber am 15
April sollen sie abgestellt werden
spätestens dann und danach soll es keine
Atomenergie in Deutschland mehr geben
ganz wichtig auch es sollen keine neuen
Brennstäbe beschafft werden das ist der
Kompromiss den quasi der Bundeskanzler
für die streitende Ampel im Oktober
festgeschrieben hatte sie erinnern sich
es gab das Machtwort des Bundeskanzlers
der genau diese Lösung empfohlen hat
nachdem die Bündnisgrünen den
Atomausstieg bis zum 31.12 eigentlich an
dem festhalten wollten dann aber
aufgrund auch des Krieges in der Ukraine
und der Problematiken was die
Energieversorgung angeht gesagt haben
okay die zwei süddeutschen Kraftwerke
die können als Einsatzreserve sozusagen
noch am Netz bleiben und dann abberufen
werden wenn wir sie brauchen und die FDP
hat damals argumentiert dass es zu wenig
wir brauchen auch für den Winter 23 24
eine Versorgung mit ordentlichem Strom
auch schon wegen der Preise und deswegen
brauchen wir längere Laufzeiten der AKWs
der Bundeskanzler hat dann von seiner
sogenannten
richtlinienkompetenzgebrauch gemacht und
diese diesen Kompromiss über den jetzt
hier abgestimmt wird eben quasi
aufgrund seiner Richtlinienkompetenz
dieser Ampel mitgegeben das war eine
große Belastungsprobe im Oktober für die
Ampel aber Olaf Scholz hat sie auf diese
Art und Weise
geregelt und die
736 Abgeordneten ich sagte es gerade sie
sehen Sie hier an den Urnen im Flur
schön dass wir das auch sehen können
müssen jetzt ihre Stimmkarten einstecken
sind damit aber noch lange nicht fertig
denn danach kommt noch ein Gesetzentwurf
der
cdu/csu die eine längere Laufzeit der
AKWs wünschen und dann eine
Beschlussempfehlung zu einem Antrag der
AFD der im Großen und Ganzen ebenfalls
längere Laufzeiten und eine Erforschung
der Atomkraft auch in Zukunft in
Deutschland sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat
und zehn Minuten wird jetzt über diesen
ersten Antrag der Ampel abgestimmt nein
über den ersten Gesetzentwurf der Ampel
abgestimmt muss ich sagen dann werden
die Urnen getauscht wir haben es gehört
deswegen eine ganz kurze zusatzpause und
danach dann 10 Minuten Abstimmung über
den unionsentwurf dann wenn die Ohren
wieder getauscht und dann 10 Minuten
Abstimmung über
den Antrag der AFD so ist das Prozedere
alles ein bisschen kompliziert muss aber
alles seine Ordnung haben wir haben mal
gerechnet übrigens
416 Abgeordnete hätte die Ampel hier im
Deutschen Bundestag die Mehrheit 369
dürfte nicht in Gefahr sein wenn gleich
sie eben ja auch Bärbel Bars gehört
haben bei der zweiten namentlichen
Abstimmung zu dem Gesetz der Ampel gab
es Gegenstimmen der bündnisgrün das war
früher auch angekündigt worden es gibt
doch den ein oder anderen grünen der
diesen dieses Machtwort des
Bundeskanzlers diesen Kompromiss sage
ich mal nicht mitgehen will und deswegen
wird es sicherlich nicht alle Stimmen
aus der Ampel für den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung hier gleich geben